c'est un amerrissage à l'ancienne avec
des rechutes comme montant des missions
apollo ou gemini c'est la première fois
qu'on récupère une capsule spatiale de
cette façon depuis 50 ans une étape
cruciale pour le retour des vols habités
de la nasa
le vaisseau spéciales cros draghi a
visiblement réussi son grand test en
ramenant sur terre sont uniques
passagers un mannequin nommé replay haut
l'honneur de l'héroïne de la série
éoliennes un succès qui signifie de
nombreux contrats pour spacex
l'entreprise dit le masque après sa
mission de ravitaillement de séjour pour
les trois astronautes en orbite dont le
canadien david saint jacques
le vaisseau cloud dragan s'est détachée
sans problème vendredi matin de la
station spatiale internationale pour
entamer son voyage de retour depuis huit
ans les américains doivent compter sur
les vaisseaux russes soyouz pour
transporter leurs astronautes
deux astronautes de la nasa john curry
et bob behnken prendront part un vol
habité de spacex en juillet prochain
doug hurley a fait partie de l'équipage
du dernier vol d'une navette spatiale
ici monsieur marsolais radio canada
montréal